we got this story did you guys see this
story uh liberal washington square park
residents say they are afraid of asking
for more cops because they don't want to
be viewed as less progressive as
professor claims complaints over noisy
park raves are targeting young people of
color
oh that last part y'all can just shut up
but could you imagine being that much of
like a loser that you're like i'm going
to keep living in the city
that's being ravaged by crime and
murders and
it's lawless and people are partying and
then uh you know
snitch is not gonna leave now i'm not
gonna leave or ask for more cops because
i don't want people to know
the twitter mob will come after you say
you're not progressive enough if you
call the cops
have you guys ever read or watched the
stand the stephen king thing
there's so there's there's the stan is a
new show on paramount
and uh it's about a plague that wipes
out all of humanity
and then people start having dreams
where there's like a guy and a woman and
it's like
what's the name alexander skarsgard or
whoopi goldberg and they're like come to
this place and join me
and it's basically like the devil and
god and this is really fascinating and
it does relate to this uh bear with me
because i'm watching it now i think i'm
on like episode six or something and
the devil sets up his post-apocalyptic
world in las vegas
where it's all sorts of just like
debauchery and lewd lascivious behavior
people have jobs you know they make the
city work there's electricity and
there's food
but for the most part they're all just
drinking and getting drunk and doing
drugs
and they're like there's like a scene
where it shows a bunch of people having
a massive orgy just like
in this main floor that's the devil
advocating for that and then like
the place where god is calling people
it's like wholesome
community sunny and happy boulder
colorado and
smiles and howdy neighbor and they're
sucks let's be real and it's like i just
thought it was interesting that
when stephen king wrote this the idea of
vegas was evil the idea of these parties
in the streets were wrong
and the orgies and all that stuff was
like wrong and sinful
and you know debauchery and now it's
funny because what's happening in new
york is like i'm not gonna say it's
exactly the same as the stand
but there is there's a funny little
thing there like you know this this
pandemic hits and then
all the all the you know politics
everything is disrupted now you've got
these raves happening in the park and
no one will speak up because they're all
scared and like
there it is like it's the decay you know
what i mean yeah absolutely and it's
true that historically people have
engaged in
a lot of the same behavior that we see
today there's nothing new under the sun
so when you're talking about vegas being
viewed as evil
typically people would do those things
but they also were ashamed of it they
recognized that it was wrong and they
didn't really seek to normalize it as
often
but then people had to normalize it now
that it's normalized it's actually being
promoted as a virtue if you're against
it you're one of the bad guys
well that's what's what's strange about
it it's certainly what's happening on
the ground like in washington square
park
and in many places where like that look
that toddler twerking in times square
that's so disgusting right right like
it's like
wow i mean man and the cat and the crowd
was cheering it on yeah i know the
entire crowd it's insane
and this is like i'm just like it's the
okay i'm not a religious person but it's
like you watch the stand and it's
literally the devil
who's encouraging all of that stuff you
know what i mean and then this video
goes viral of a toddler she's what like
four years old
and that's happening in times square so
you've got people who move to the cities
after the pandemic and they're certainly
planted up like they're hanging out with
the uh
the devil and then you've got people
moving out of the country being
responsible for themselves being more
self-sufficient
not polluting well and this is also part
of what the founders were saying when
they were discussing the fact that for
the constitution or any limited
government system to work you have to
have a populist with virtue
do you think the people who are cheering
on a two-year-old twerking are really
going to be good at governing themselves
do you think those people make good
decisions
do you think they behave morally
absolutely did you guys did you guys see
the orlando bloom thing
yes katy perry orlando bloom and like
old and they like run into a room and
they're like quick we have to make it
work and then it's like
oh there's like a year it's like 20 50
and then it winds back at 2021 it's like
broadcasting in 2021
and then like everyone's tvs get taken
over and their phones get taken over
which makes literally no sense but
and then they're like you've got to stop
the republicans their voting laws
they took away our right to vote and oh
no they're coming for us now we have no
voice
and it's like you must pass the
democrats voter reform bill or whatever
the first funny thing about it is like
you don't broadcast the phones that way
that was like the stupidest thing ever
like someone looks at their phone their
phone just gets taken over i guess that
could work with like trump's new text
messaging thing
exactly where it's like don't have
facebook hack your phone zuckerberg will
find some way to work that in
i guess it's possible to do it through
these back doors and stuff like that but
just like the idea that the republicans
who are ending the emergency provisions
and returning the voting
laws back to normal is evil and like
going to create a dystopian future
man these people are lunatics absolutely
no disagreement there
and this is sort of what i was getting
at it gets to the point where people
become so vicious that they're literally
blinded from seeing reality so
classically it was understood
that what intelligence was was the
ability to see the world for what it is
and act on it that's not necessarily
your processing power
not your long-term or short-term memory
but how clearly you saw the world
and people also understood that the more
vicious you were the more interested you
were in pursuing pleasure and therefore
the less interested you were in pursuing
truth
so you can't expect these people to come
up with ideas that are solid for running
a democratic system or any kind of a
system when they can't even govern their
own lives virtuously
i gotta i got a solution what is it what
we'll do is
we will build a very large beautiful
glass
bridge called the unity bridge okay and
what we'll do is we'll encourage
all of those who believe in anti-racism
and these ideas
to come together to stand atop this
bridge holding hands
and then just to prove that we agree
with them and support their ideology
in terms of the architecture for a
payload uh of this bridge
we'll we'll we'll we'll calculate two
plus two as equaling five
yes the diversity bridge right and then
as they stand atop it
i'm sure everything will be fine using
those calculations i love it and then
you know and we'll leave they should
just have to live by those rules or or
whatever system of mathematics you want
to develop works well we'll do this
we'll take elon's rocket
we'll put them all in you know as a big
sign of
solidarity and then we'll go in the
computer and change all the the software
and and uh we'll we'll take all
instances of two plus two equaling four
and change it to five and then see how
the rocket performs so so
wouldn't it be an extension is this is
this an extension of mars-ism
i'm just curious to send them all yeah
this is two plus two equals fiveism
if you believe it that much how about
you put your money while your mouth is
that's right
when we look at new york city we see it
we see a city that was one of the most
prominent one of the most beautiful one
of the most authentic one of the most
grassroots cities in the united states
it used to be chicago out of here used
to be when
had elements of we're asking for a date
luke listen here listen you're not
scared around no listen here
it used to be something that used to
represent authenticity
maybe but it has been absolutely
destroyed by big government and whether
it was giuliani whether it was bloomberg
whether it was dinkins whether
it was de blasio they have absolutely
ruined it why because they started to
intervene take over all the small
businesses that were able to succeed
there no longer could succeed it's only
mass corporations
people are being fleeced more and more
of their wealth is being taken away
they were locked up more than any other
place in the country and that's why now
they're partying they're having crazy
raves in washington square
and some of the people who don't want to
rave who are annoyed who
are acting like you know some would say
karen they're like hey
i'm paying almost more than half of my
income
to be protected and served and i'm not
being protected in service at all
and then and i think everyone even the
ravers and even the karen's out there
they're waking up like hey
this was a really bad idea no i think
that that's right first don't have money
so what happens is the business owners
the homeowners the property owners
are paying meanwhile the people who are
broke are just
marching and partying through the
streets and just trashing and smashing
who would want to live there well
exactly what happens is the incentive
structure becomes misaligned and so
people who don't
see into the future and aren't
responsible move into these cities and
the people who are actually responsible
and take care of themselves and frankly
do everything for everyone else leave
and the entire thing collapses
like to uh gold's gulch oh is that
what's happening
i don't know i'm not familiar with the
reference really no who is john gold
oh gold skull yes of course my favorite
that's really better
i like my whole my favorite book atlas
shroud
all the people who produce leaf yes no
and then
just crumbles i'm very happy i left
there i was barely there even before
that because i was traveling all around
but but
i'm so much happier uh there's not just
taxes that you save them but so much
stress the environment is so much better
outside and and just
life in general is worth living when
you're not
always smelling soiled milk where
there's not cockroaches
where there's not rats where there's not
people
you know that just throw garbage all
over the street and i go back
you know sporadically sometimes and it's
horrifying like i was conditioned to
live here
like this is a crap hole that that is
filled with junkies there's garbage
everywhere
i mean the services that the city
provides are absolutely insane and
it's only going to get worse as there's
eight an estimated
8 000 people being held up that are
homeless in
midtown hotels that are about to be
released because the city is about to
stop paying these hotels
to house 8 000 homeless people and the
city also announced
a 2.5 million program that will be
handed out
and giving out homeless people a
thousand two hundred fifty dollars each
if they are black latinx or lgbtq
if you're asian or white and you're
homeless you don't qualify for this
program and you won't be paid
to be homeless essentially because
people are arguing yes you can't afford
not to do that
you're asking at south park with the
homeless people yes yes that's like
what's going to happen
yeah it's going to be like people you
know they're going to be walking outside
and it's going to be
it's going to be people everywhere what
you know what you know what really oh
man it really you don't really grind my
gears
gravel institute oh my god they tweeted
like for every homeless person there's
30 empty homes oh yeah we've talked
about this and i'm like
stupid these guys who run this are
probably like
they're in their early 20s they have no
concept of economics
it's just like some dude sitting there
like we talk about it all the time some
little kid going like
capitalism is so stupid like if you have
an empty house and like a homeless
person just put the person in the house
and then the adult in the room was like
and who will pay for the maintenance of
that building
and the bills and the water and fix
damage and prevent fires
and make sure the building doesn't fall
down in the man and
what happens what will he eat where will
he sleep what do you do you put him in a
building do you buy him clothes you get
him furniture do you get him a job what
does he eat what do you do you
know that argument is sweeping people
under the rug
so that these uppity liberals in new
york don't have to look at these people
scumbags they're in hotels right now the
problem with homelessness
is not the fact that there is a lack of
housing or that these people don't have
places to stay often it's an issue with
addiction
or serious mental illness problems and i
think that's horrible i believe we need
to do everything we can with private
charity and even if private charity
isn't capable of handling it then some
kind of social safety net outside of the
private charity maybe something
government funded them very reluctant
i would say this though it's clear that
it's not as if these people are all just
thrown out of their houses
and it also goes to show that i think a
lot of people on the left just don't
talk to homeless people or poor people
one of the first things a homeless
person will tell me when i speak with
them this is a very common theme
especially among homeless men
which most homeless people are is don't
do drugs
don't mess around with alcohol almost
all the time and they'll tell me that
they screwed their lives up with this
not always
but it's a pretty common theme and so my
heart goes out to them i think we need
to do what we can as a society to help
those people but it's clearly not an
issue
of these people just not accessing
housing it's that they have serious
problems where they cannot take care of
themselves in many instances and just
putting them in an empty house doesn't
solve that
well another thing we have to really
calculate here is the rise
of the mental health crisis which has
been not only exacerbated but keeps
dramatically
increasing by the year if you look at
the levels of anxiety depression
self-harm psychological disorders all of
them are up
dramatically and they continue to go up
and there's nothing that
that is helping the number of cases the
number of mentally ill people
going down it's only a trajectory that
that has
been going up and will continue to go up
and with that will become
more problems i i don't know private
charity i don't think will help solve
the problem i think that's you know
that's a very optimistic thinking to say
at least
i'm certainly not saying that we're
going to eliminate how can we ever yeah
how can we deal with this
problem i mean it's also very hard
because how do you help
you know someone who is not well in the
head
obviously if someone is well-meaning and
has a string of bad luck i mean
obviously
you know family members and and
communities and neighborhoods
if someone is a good person should go
out there and help them yes not always
do they but they should
uh but also not always do the people who
are going through problems want to be
helped
or that help will actually cause more
damage and problems for them
and there's also that aspect of it so
this is a problem that you can't have on
one
definitive solution for but i but one of
the definitive conclusions is that
whenever the government intervenes it
makes the problem
that much worse and that's exactly what
they're doing yeah almost always what i
would say
is mostly agree with all that these
problems have to be solved on a very
very local level and you sort of hint at
that when you talk about all these cases
being different
almost at the level of the individual is
how it has to be approached but small
communities have to be doing what they
can to take care of the homeless that
are there or try to solve that issue
this isn't something that could even
conceivably be handled on the federal
level or probably even the state level
a lot of you're just trying to you're
too removed there's a certain
contingency for sure
i would say that in my experience almost
every single homeless person i
encountered chose to be homeless yep
that's not been my experience i worked
for a homeless shelter network of them
so and when the vans would come pull up
to a homeless person and say
you have an option you have several
options we can give you supplies
we can bring you to a temporary shelter
or we can apply for a long-term shelter
and find you work you know what they
would say
no yeah that's very sad that's very sad
almost every single time
the van would come back empty they just
don't want to they don't want to go to
the shelter
yeah and sometimes they would go in for
a shower for a night and just leave and
never come back
or you know come back once a month for a
quick cleanup which is i guess it's
still a good thing it's it's good the
shelters are providing that but uh the
overwhelming majority like
in in my experience it was almost every
single instance
yeah i mean i've definitely known
homeless people who were
seeking shelter but i don't doubt that
that was your experience at all
yeah yeah man and that's what really
bothers me about
the the modern left that we have and
maybe it's always the case it's because
you've got the exploitative class which
is the you know the democrats
they see how stupid and naive and
ignorant people can be
they target those who are the least
least experienced like they want 16 year
olds to vote why because 16 year olds
have no grasp of history
a 16 year old doesn't remember the mor
the banking crisis
a 16 year old today is going to be like
i have no idea what happened in 2008
you know it's like okay well you were a
little you were barely alive at that
point you were you know
a couple years old so yeah they have no
idea then the democrats who are in their
80s
can propose insane things to extract
value and and continue to destroy and
erode this country
it's just the stupidest thing in the
world these are these are people who
and with all due respect 16 year olds
hey could be very smart don't have the
experience
but don't have the memory because they
weren't alive like when we talk with
these leftists who are in their 20s
they're like
i don't remember occupy wall street i
was 10. it's like okay well that's
really important context for what's
happening
if you want to understand how we got
donald trump you gotta go back to 2008.
if you don't even remember occupy wall
street
then you don't remember you don't
remember the economic crisis
then i'm sorry man like you are out of
this conversation
the problem is these people are part of
the political process and they have no
idea what's going on but let me let me
tell you what things
can i can i just throw something about
voting once upon a time in this country
you had to be 21 to vote
and early on in our history you were out
taking care of yourself by the time you
were 16 so you had several years of life
experience before you were ever able to
vote
and now kids still aren't ready to live
life
and provide for themselves by the time
they're 18 in their voting and people
want to walk that back to 16. it's
completely insane
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you